I think that San Juan represents one of
the great investment opportunities my
generation Nick rowdy is betting on the
promise of Puerto Rico he's not only
making significant investments on the
island he's moved his office and family
from Greenwich Connecticut this is Dan
one last year I think I spent about 10
or 15 days outside of Puerto Rico you
know we're all in you know we're not
going home on the weekend to attract
investors like Trouty the Puerto Rican
government created acts 20 and 22 which
offer tax exemptions to businesses that
export their services from Puerto Rico
to outside markets and the individuals
who relocate to the either the
government forecast that 250 individual
investors will apply for the apt 22
program in 2014 my phone rings at this
point you know three or four times a
week with people wanting to know a
little bit more local businesses are
welcoming the interest as well as the
investment are you seeing a shift are
you seeing companies start to move here
for sure I'm seeing an in aerospace I'm
seeing it and I know their areas I have
seen more people come to Puerto Rico in
the last two years and I've seen in a
lot of time one of the biggest
advantages of act 20 and 22 it's not
even so much how many wealthy people
come down how much way they spend but
it's putting Puerto Rico back on the map
the area's new visibility is attracting
a wide range of investors at the high
end is billionaire John Paulson who
hasn't moved to the island but he's
committed hundreds of millions of
dollars to buy and remodel the historic
condado Vanderbilt Resort he has a
vision and he is willing to put his
money where his vision is by all
indications were token investors don't
present competition from tax advantaged
Outsiders the capital they bring with
them is simply too important the truth
of the matter is if we didn't have these
laws they wouldn't be here and so
they're only bringing incremental
benefits to Puerto Rico what are our
options
having the real-estate developments die
and go away or crumble is working is
really working we are receiving a lot of
intrapreneurs that are partnering with
our people creating jobs and we are
really happy with the problem